all right
hi and welcome to robotics today my name
is luca carlone and i'm excited to
introduce dr
raya hatzel as our speaker today
rai is the director of robotics at
deepmind her research focuses on the
challenge of continual learning for ai
agents and robots
and she has proposed popular neural
approaches such as policy distillation
progressive nets in elastic weight
consolidation
to solve the problem of catastrophic
forgetting
let me say that raya had a quite unique
career path
after an undergraduate degree in
religion and philosophy from reid
college
she started to be interested in computer
science and ended up doing a phd with
jan lacoon
at nyu focusing on machine learning for
robotics
she did a postdoc at cmu working with
drew bucknell and marshall hebert
and then became a research scientist in
the vision and robotics group
at sri international finally she joined
deep mind in 2014
to pursue new solutions for artificial
general intelligence
leia's work has been widely recognized
her thesis about
learning long-range vision for off-road
robots was awarded the outstanding
dissertation award
in 2009 she's on the executive boards of
iclr women in machine learning and coral
she is a fellow of the european lab on
learning system
and serves as a seafarer advisor
raya thanks for being here the stage is
yours
thank you very much luca i'm looking
forward to giving the talk thanks to the
invitation and uh for the introduction
let's see here
i'm going to talk a little bit about uh
what i think would be a few different
directions where we could go
to um a little bit of a different way
to think about machine learning
and robotics but let me start first with
deep learning
so as we all know now deep learning is
powerful
because we've got big data and we've got
these wonderful
architectures uh these uh deep learning
models
that really scale very well to fit the
data set
and there's always sort of this notion
of that we've got
a lot of data we've got this and we've
got this big model and when the two
scale together
then we can really achieve impressive
things
um this is well supported by large scale
compute
and by end to end optimization
now you can think about d bar l as
looking a little bit the same
again sorry microphone problems again we
are thinking about
um a a certain balance
that we might imagine between an agent
that we're training
and an environment that we're learning
in um with the difference
being that of course in deep
reinforcement learning
then we're thinking about uh the agent
is actually generating its own data set
that it's learning from
by taking actions in the environment and
learning from the observations that come
back
in order to maximize reward
so yes the the agent builds its own data
set um
and and and with this
sort of simple view of it in a lot of
ways
we've been able to come up with a lot of
interesting things
we've been able to optimize
over behaviors and discover things
that are not obvious and not easy to
directly
encode such as behavior of course of
this agent that's learning to play
an atari game um and we cannot
using almost exactly the same approach
we can also see
impressive behaviors emerging when we
train an agent to for instance
simply maximize its forward velocity
so this 56-dimensional humanoid
model can be taught to run
across a terrain and jump across gaps in
quite an impressive way
this agent was optimized for a very long
time until it
could could solve this task really
really well um and why does this work
again because we've got
an agent that is powerful enough that it
can fit
to that environment that we've given it
it's essentially memorizing the entire
environment why it optimizes so well
um but and and this is this is
impressive it's fun it's interesting but
we want to go a little bit beyond this
we want to move ai research beyond the
simple picture of having
an agent and an environment and where
the agent can
fully fit to that environment
instead i would say that we want agents
that are actually much smaller
than the environments that they learn
such that there's no hope that that
agent can actually
fit the whole environment um
why would we want that why would we want
agents uh
that have uh that that are dwarfed by
the size the complexity or the richness
of the environment
um such that the capacity of the agent
is not sufficient to model that
environment
well we want this it's important because
it's the driver of i would argue many
wonderful things that we we look for in
our research that should transfer
so only by having an agent that is does
not have sufficient capacity
to just learn the entire environment
only by having to that
that imbalance do we need to become
better at things like
transfer and generalization and also
fast adaptation
if the environment is small the agent
can just learn the whole thing
but instead we can also have continual
learning
there's no need for continual learning
if you can observe the entire
environment you can learn it all but if
we have this imbalance
then this can drive continual learning
can also drive
causal reasoning uh causal reasoning
comes from
needing to have more efficient ways of
understanding the relationships and the
dynamics of environments
that can't come from simple from uh
memorizing from
from observing everything and abstract
concepts
so first question how do we make an
environment complex what does that even
mean
um is an atari environment complex is
a uh is a humanoid control environment
complex
well we can think about a few different
dimensions
of complexity so first of all the
observations that an agent takes in an
environment
real data has much more complexity
than in a simulation so although i use
stimulation in my research
i think that it's important to recognize
the value
of real data for
it the the noise and the complexity that
is expressed there
there's also partial observability so um
of course if you can see everything in
an environment
and it's definitely not going to be as
complex as if i can only see
through a bit of a soda straw through a
limited view
over time there's also multiple sensory
modalities
so if there is a if there is not only
vision but also audio
uh touch information um
etc environment then it will be more
complex
you can also look at the dynamics of an
environment things like interactions
and contacts having multiple agents
and this greatly multiplies the the
complexity and then you can think about
the world itself
so a lot of research environments that
we look at or task environments for
training robots or agents um tend to be
very short-lived we think about maybe an
environment where we can perfectly reset
things and have episodes that last very
on the order of seconds instead we can
think about the length of time
of of our the life of our agents the
experience of the agents
and we can think about worlds that are
persistent where changes made by
one agent at one time would persist
through
uh and and those changes would be
evident
to a to another agent at another time
all right so let's turn to how an agent
can learn in very complex environments
uh so one way is through uh learning
with multiple objectives
so one way i believe to deal with the
fact
of having a lower capacity agent
and a more complex world is to
use multiple reinforcement learning
objectives for instance multiple rewards
constraints penalties
there should be a rich scope of things
that an agent is trying to achieve
in any given environment
there can also be of course
reward is not the only way in which we
can learn we can also
include supervised learning and
unsupervised learning
of all of the parts of the cake as my
advisor would say
former advisor would say
another approach is to learn with many
tasks or skills so rather than learning
a single skill such as running with
forward velocity to the end of a track
as that humanoid was trained to do
instead
learning to do many different things in
one environment is
a is is a a great way for an
agent to learn some of the different
notions of
transfer of abstract concepts causality
etc
and then the last point that i would
make here is that learning with humans
is something that we
could do more of to enable agents to
learn
even in these more complex environments
and that can include learning from
demonstrations or learning through
imitation for instance from a third
person perspective
simple observation i think that
agents that can be can be
taught just to learn from observing
others in a complex world this can be
valuable i think about this every time
i'm out
out in the world with other humans and
watching them and realizing
i don't need to imitate them i learn
through simply observing what they do
and that's the outcomes of their
behaviors and
and and through language as well so
these are all sorts of areas this is
very general but i just think that these
are
uh are
that we as as a research community
is spending a lot of time on um
optimizing
for smaller domains and maybe simpler
approaches
when really we need to embrace the
complexity of agents as well as the
environments that they learn
so let me present a couple of a couple
of research results that we've
had recently at deepmind
um so the first one and these are
both of these methods are about
imitation
but imitation used in very different
ways
so imitation can be used as
as as a source of data as a way to learn
the fundamentals
movement the fundamentals of control
or it can be used at sort of the other
end of learning in order to give a
demonstration
for uh to demonstrate a task that needs
to be done
so i like to think about these these two
different sides
of using expert data
one at the beginning to learn
representations and one at the end
to to demonstrate goals so this
first work is about using mimicry
to learn basic motor control
all right so why do we want to learn
reusable skills
um well um
learning from scratch can be data
efficient
just showing here um this old parkour
video that probably people have seen
before
the internet seemed to like like this
video
um and you know this this
this showed some impressively robust
uh control behavior and skills
um but we do end up in
in a regime where this is data
inefficient
and where the
where we don't have a lot of constraint
of the behavior of
of the agent over time so exploration
is is limited and transfer is limited
so how can we learn reusable skills well
we could um there are unsupervised skill
discovery methods
um you could learn from a lot of simple
tasks
for instance by the method called
scheduled auxiliary control
or you could use demonstrations which is
what this work is based on
or do specifically do joint training
with tasks and demonstrations
so let me start by mentioning neural
probabilistic motor primitives
this is or otherwise called npmp
and the idea here is to
train a an expert policy
by tracking kinematic motion capture
clips
and then to force the policy to be
bottlenecked through a latent layer that
can then be reused
so basically we're going to take some
sets of clips
here of different types of uh human
motion
um coming from human motion capture
and we're going to learn
to predict uh we're going to learn to
encode the
the the future state
go through a latent state which we can
interpret as being a latent
intention and that's going to then go to
a decoder which will produce
an action um we also feed in the present
state the proprioception of the current
robot
and the output action tries to imitate
um
the next state of these clips so
basically we're trying to learn
to uh follow each of these over time by
controlling a human
or by controlling a humanoid figure
um and the key thing is that this
latent intention is then
is is used to develop this latent
embedding
zt
we can then reuse exactly the same
decoder
now we've learned how to go from a
from an input in the state in the
embedding
we've learned to go from that directly
to actions
so now this becomes the action space and
we can
learn a task policy that's going to
control this so now
given an rl environment given some tasks
that we want to
do from reward then we can reuse the
decoder
as a low-level skill module so we're
going to take an observation
from this task space whatever that is
and then we're going to learn how to
um create an action in this embedding
space
um it's not necessarily a lower
dimensional space
in this case the action space 56
dimensional
and the embedding space is 60
dimensional
but that embedding space at least has
within it all of the different types of
motion
that we might expect a humanoid
character to do
does not have a lot of laying on the
ground and flailing around because that
set of expert clips does not contain
that type of
behavior instead it has productive
movement locomotion sitting turning
standing
jumping etc so this is
a a a a really nice and efficient way
of learning uh learning low-level motor
behavior and then being able to reuse it
for reinforcement learning um
so the work in this paper uh in in
comics
instead says this is a little bit
inefficient to do these things in two
separate spaces
let's instead put it all together into
one rl environment
um so now we're going to
take these both together we're going to
say i'm going to take these expert clips
and i'm going to try to imitate them
and i'm also going to take observations
from tasks that i'm learning at the same
time
for instance go through this obstacle
course
and i'm going to push both these
i'm going to learn to use zed at the
same time this embedding space
as a latent intention space which tries
to do imitation
and also as a high level action space to
fulfill my
my task policy and i'm going to reward
both the uh
the imitations and i'm going to reward
the tasks using
quite different rewards one is a reward
that comes from
uh following each joint position
um of the uh of
of the mocap data we're trying to track
and the other one is as far as reward
from velocity
so the research questions that come we
sort of got this working together these
two different parts put them together
and said let's just train the whole
thing at the same time co-training
and mimicry but then we wanted to say
well
how do the different architectures we
could use compare
here how do they compare in terms of the
tracking performance how do they compare
in terms of reusability
and how well does the joint training
approach work
so in order to evaluate this we use a
motion capture data set from
cmu from the cmu motion capture data set
and a the humanoid model like i said
with 56 degrees of freedom
and in each episode we sample a starting
point
from a lot of different clips and use a
reward similar to
the deep mimic paper and
where we have terms that are weighted to
match
different positions joint orientation
we trade this using uh on policy
rls um using the
npo um the links are there for
more information about these these
different approaches
and using pale regularization of the
skill and betting space of that latent
space which is important
um to make this work well and then we
tried out some different low-level
architectures
so how do we want to have that decoder
that action decoder that becomes this
motor module how do we want to
uh and how do we want to represent that
so i looked at an mlp we looked at lstms
mixture of gaussians or products of
gaussian
that's based which have all been used uh
in in previous works
uh with with with with different success
and we just wanted to compare against
these um
and then uh so we can look at different
motion capture data sets
and how they are valuable so there are
two small ones one with just walking
one with just running one that has more
uh
larger locomotion different a lot of
different clips there
summing up to 40 minutes of data and
then we have a large sort of un
larger set of clips that has much longer
sequences in it and
a lot more motion three and a half hours
long
for the transfer for the joint training
then we looked at a couple of different
tasks
first we have a go to go to doc task
go to target task task
and then two different parkour type of
tasks where the humanoid needs to
traverse
gaps or wall wall obstacles
these tasks have a dense reward and they
have egocentric
visual observations so these aren't done
from state information but they're
actually done from visual information
proprioception is available as well
um and we also
specifically looked at a couple of tasks
that we knew
were not represented in the in the data
of the uh original data sets
so being able to get up from laying down
is something that's not present in the
in the uh in the motion capture data
sets
so we knew that this is something that
would need to be learned separately
and the other one was catching an object
which is not represented in the data set
so when we look at just learning the
tracking performance learning to track
the
learning to track the motion capture
data sets uh then we can see that the
best architecture is the lstm
um so this performs well across all of
the different data regimes whether or
not we have a small amount of data
or the very largest set the mlp also
performed well
in all settings
i can take a look at this tracking
performance that is learned
in joint with the task if we just look
at the the tracking performance
this is on the largest data set and we
can imitate various walking and running
behaviors so the character
in silver is the human motion capture
and the one
in gold is the one that uh the agent is
controlling
and probably you saw that little glitch
there
where um it just decides i'm not going
to try to do that fancy spin that the uh
that's done in the motion capture data
and the agent sort of
it skips past that
quite opportunistically
but in general we see that all of the
behaviors can be
robustly followed including walking
backwards dancing
etc
now if we look at transfer so here we
have transfer
to the go to target task the walls task
and the gaps task starting with
with with low-level controllers that are
trained on either the walking
running the locomotion or the large
datasets and we see that all of these
cases even though the lstm
did the best in the actual tracking test
um
then it's the mlp that does decidedly
better
um and this works across the the mlp
works
across almost every one of the tests
that we did
for that transfer the lstm
low-level policies are
probably less reliant on the embedding
space
they're probably memorizing the data a
little bit more
um whereas the mlp is forced to stay a
little bit more tied a little bit more
reliant on the embedding space so it's
going to do better
for transfer
here's a video showing one of the models
traverse and obstacle course with gaps
this was trained simultaneously with the
agent
so the gaps task is not present in the
in the training regime and it does do
quite well
on this training
let's take a look one more time now
compared with the original parkour
agent that i showed you that is
galloping across this gas gap task this
agent does not do
quite as well that's because it's
actually constrained by the
uh by the latent space now training on
this task
is no longer training all the way end to
end but instead stop the training stops
at his
uh at the at the latent embedding
and therefore you don't get quite that
full optimization that you get
if you only train for the uh
for this task from scratch on the other
hand
this was able to be trained in a matter
of minutes
rather than days and
it is
uses a bit less energy and as a in terms
of the
uh we look at the um
the actions that are taken um
and is a bit more constrained in terms
of of what it learned
so we see this transfer as being
important even though it doesn't get
quite the same performance as the
as the original parkour agent that can
run through very quickly
i think i'm gonna i'm going to move on
to the uh
to the next piece of research that i
wanted to talk about
um there's more details in this paper
which i would encourage people to look
at there's a longer
video and website that shows more of the
results
and some of the co-training results that
i'm not going to go into here
so as i said there's different ways to
use
expert data one way in which i just
showed is to use expert data as the
starting point
expert data as a way to quickly
more quick efficiently get to a
low-level representation
that has been reusable the other way in
which we would want to use
used demonstrations for robotics is to
use it as
the end point to give us targets to
demonstrate a task and then being able
to quickly
execute that path so that's what this
this next book focuses on the title of
this is manipulator independent
representation learning for visual
imitation
so the the work focuses
on third person imitation for robotics
manipulation
and the challenge here is to is
imitation from pixels
um so this video
this uh this uh sort of crude rendering
shows a tele operation that we might
want to do
where we demonstrate moving a block and
pi and stacking it on top of
another block what we would like to do
is be able to take something
from this simple information that's
shown
and be able to replicate this with a
real robot real world
or even better being able to demonstrate
something like this with a human hand
and then repeat it with a robot
and it's important to say that we don't
we want to be able to
we don't want to have to use the
tele operation of the robot directly but
be able to do this imitation just from
third person imitation so not have
uh task rewards not have proprioception
not have actions
simply have this visual space and be
able to imitate from that
and the challenge is of course that we
have this domain gap we have a
sort of in simulation things that that
look
um one way and then in the real world
then things are going to look
quite different or we could have human
hands we could have grippers
that could move things around um
and so we really need to learn and uh
extreme levels of uh invariance
or robustness if we want to be able to
imitate
from this type of demonstration
so the approach here i will
uh point to this this figure here where
what we see is a hand that is
demonstrating
a stacking of one block on top of
another
block human is here doing this
and we want to send the
sort of first waypoints along the way we
want to send
that through an encoder
to a to a representation space to a
feature space
and then use that as a goal for an
imitating agent
to be able to follow the same action
there are related works in this area so
here is the
imitation the npmp work that we just
showed and there's lots lots of other
work that's been done
in demonstrating imitation learning
um a lot of this happens in model
dependent state space
and often for locomotion
existing approaches from pixels are
often applied
in the same domain or where there's a
really limited domain gap
or requires manually labeled data for
instance doing post extractions
so the approach that we have here
is to is to focus on
the representation needed in order to do
this third person visualization so
uh the main properties
of the feature space we would like is
that we would like to be able to do
cross-domain
alignment so when we go from a real
robot to a simulated robot or a real arm
a human arm to a robot arm from one type
of robot to another type of robot
we want to be able to align those
different
domain trajectories we want the feature
space to exhibit temporal smoothness
and we want there to be actionable
representations
meaning that the information in that
feature space
is sufficient that we can take uh that
that we can take actions the agent can
learn to take actions with respect to
that
um which means embedding the uh the the
actions
in that in that imbalances
so
we use the fact that we have
simulation we have access to uh
in simulation to being able to produce
a high degree of domain randomization
um but moreover we can not only
randomize the domain we can also
remove the arm entirely
so and you can still see here that the
block
one block is being stacked on top of
another block
even though the arm is invisible all
together
this is just because we're choosing not
to render that
and this but we can have these align
trajectories
we can also align trajectories where we
randomize the entire domain
and where we've randomized just the
feature visual features
of the arm
so these different um these
these different randomized domains
randomized arms
and invisible arm are used in order to
build a data set
of aligned trajectories and from their
train
our encoder in order to trade the
encoder from
this data set of aligned trajectories
then we use a variant of ccn which is
temporal
contrastive networks time-contrasted
networks
which we call a temporal smooth
contrastive networks
and we train
goal condition policies across the
domain so
we want to be able to
pair pair trajectories and
learn the right learn the action that
was
taken in either case across these
different
these different domains and then we can
train
to get to a next goal position
from the current observation using
reinforcement learning
all right so uh here we look a little
bit
into that represents that feature space
to see
how the distances are
in the embedded space so we can take
a robot arm
at the first time time step and compare
it to
a human hand
moving through a given motion over 200
times steps
and we can look at the distances between
these
looking at the cross domain case or in
the same domain
case and what we hope to see here is
that
um the method will have a relatively
uh smooth uh well-behaved distance
measure
across this this as it as it goes from
unaligned to more alarms
over time so this is looking at time
contrast
networks just looking at temporally
smooth contrastive networks
this is the
manipulation and variant representation
and then this is
uh cross domain um
i've forgotten what the gcp is um the
generative contrastive um
policy i believe um
basically these two are both ablations
of the last one which is manipulation
and variant
representations and so you can see that
this offers
a very nice smooth distance measure
in the same domain and also offers a
relatively smooth and accurate uh
distance measure even when we're looking
across domain between a human hand and a
robot
arm which has not been which have not
been trained for
um and
so the goal is given
by different uh waypoints every time the
video pauses here showing that
in the human hand video then we're
giving a new goal
to the agent and we see that then the
agent
uh which is this is the view that it
sees visually and then that's the larger
picture is just another rendering
and we can see it following through the
same part it goes to pick up the red
block
then it hovers over the blue block and
then it places it down and releases it
at the same time like the human hand
as it does this
so obviously the environment has been
trained on different types of blocks
different types of stacking and moving
around
but note that there is no actual reward
here that's coming from the task of
stacking
um the only reward is coming from
trying to uh get to a
um get to the goal points that are given
in the in the video the human hand
and no human hands were ever seen during
the actual trading sequence at all
it was purely trained on this um
where in in the three cases where we
have the randomized arm
the randomized environment and where we
have the invisible arms
so that's given us a level of invariance
uh
in the representation that allows us to
then match the human hand which hasn't
been seen before
and just to give a couple more examples
here on
the on on the left we see
tracking from a the real robot is shown
on the top and on the bottom the robot
is shown in simulation
and is stacking again the red block on
top of the blue this was used
just for test purposes the middle view
we show uh that the goal is being given
the demonstration is being given using a
pickup stick
um by a human but we just see the stick
and again the agent is able to
follow that and match that trajectory
and stack the block and in the last
view then we're using a different robot
arm in simulation
so this is demonstrating following
the following in different robots the
different robot arms the
jaco hand at the top an aerobatic
gripper simulated at the bottom
all right um
next i just have a a couple of
quantitative results
uh we really tried to look at this
carefully
and understand what the benefits were of
this this manipulator and variant
representation
so we looked at lifting success
and backing success across
having different types
of representations and different types
of transfers
and in each of these cases the most
successful case
is using the the
manipulation and variant representation
all right um so i find this to be
a a a nice result
that shows that one can use simulation
in a pretty simple way to achieve really
significance and variance over different
types of representations
and this has allowed us to have a an
agent that can
track relatively easily how to move
blocks around in this environment
even using demonstrations from a human
from a different point of view
and with with all of the domain gaps of
course that are here
one of the key things was in training
representation that was temporarily
smooth
um and
allowed us to
like i said achieve a level of
robustness that is a good start
for third-person visual immigration
all right these are the two papers that
i that i've invented
um second one's on archive the first one
was from icml last year
please take a look at those if you have
and contact the authors here if you have
any further questions
thanks a lot
thanks a lot raya for your great talk
thank you for your time and for going
into these
two papers really in depth um
so before we get started um so basically
the panel
and the audience have many questions
that we can't wait to discuss
and before we get started uh i just
wanted to mention to the remote audience
um that we that we do have
a way for you to ask questions so if you
go to our webpage
and to the live stream and you scroll
down you see a slider interface there
are already a few questions you can also
just upload them in
instead of asking your own and our
student panel is krishna and srinivasan
and marion uh
le pere will pick up your posted
question during the discussion
um but before we go to your uh questions
uh i would like to introduce today's
guest panelists
and uh first i welcome chelsea finn who
is the system professor at the computer
science department
at stanford university and i also
welcome
paulkut agrawal who is assistant
professor in the department of
electrical engineering and computer
science
at mit and uh chelsea um
i was wondering if you can go first with
any questions uh you have for raya
yeah so i had one lower level comment
and one higher level comment
um or question not comment
so for the second work it looked quite
cool
and i was wondering uh since it's often
not too hard to define a reward function
in simulation
i'm curious if you compared to a setting
where you did have rewards in simulation
instead of having human videos or if you
have hypotheses about how they might
compare
yeah good question um uh it's true that
we can
easily evaluate this in in
stimulation and we can uh
have those rewards and we can also look
at them on the real robot as well
um in simulation we did um
so for these sets of objects we're
able to get to
with with quite a bit of training on
that specific task
of just stacking we are able to get to
about 75 um
stacking success on the lifting grasping
stacking
um and but it does come with the cost
of having a reward that has to be um
you know that needs to be shaped in
pieces uh you know
learning to learning to to pick up
learning to
learning to stack um and learning
whether to stack red on blue or blue on
red and sort of make
conditional etcetera so this work really
did come out
of saying this is not a sustainable way
we need to sort of escape from
uh the requirements of building these
of having more and more complex tasks
uh come with these insurmountable
rewards that need to be fined
need to be tuned and trained on etc
so this agent
can get to i'd say about half of that
success
but without any uh customized
reward or training for this task at all
great yeah that makes a lot of sense and
then my second question
at a high level is at the beginning you
argue that agents should be smaller
than their environments such that the
complexity and richness exceeds the
capacity of the agent's ability to model
it and so i'm curious what you think
about
large language models which show that
we show that basically if you do scale
neural networks it does seem like they
can model considerable degrees of
complexity
of real data do you think that robotics
data is more complex than the language
data that these are modeling
do you think do you kind of agree with
that approach or do you think that we're
ultimately going to need
different approaches
it's a good question i wish that there
was
a equivalent source of natural data that
could be used
for robotics probably the closest thing
is youtube
in terms of having large large
sources of of natural data
that have that same level of diversity
and sort of breadth but i don't think
that we have a straightforward way
of learning robotics from that type
that type of data source
and
but but but yes i think that gpt 3 is
making a lot of people including
roboticists
think about how we can get to that level
of
data collection and use so that we can
train models
in that much more scaled up through this
uh sort of way
um yeah thank you very much um
um jesse and ryan for your questions uh
paul do you maybe have like uh one
question for raya
yeah thanks fire for the talk it was a
very good talk
so one question i have is on the second
part that you were talking about
manipulator invariant representation so
if for a moment you know i put on my
computer
vision hat it seems like if we had
object
representations or segmentation of
objects that would you know really help
us be manipulated in variant
but in the learning community you know
we learn we
try to learn representations from
scratch
for every task that we do right and the
reason is that segmentation methods
don't end up working
that well when we transfer them to a
robotic tasks
so i'm wondering you know what's your
perspective going forward
right i mean should we you know start
learning keep on learning
doing representation learning or maybe
try to see how
we could leverage learned segmentation
models or
you know knowledge we collect from
previous tasks so that we don't have to
learn representations for new tasks
yeah uh thanks for the
the question pocket um
i think that it is a really
important question how we bring together
uh computer vision models representation
learning for the purpose of robotics um
it's not uh
it's it's not clear that it's uh going
to be sufficient to train in this sort
of
uh bespoke way we need to be able to
again look at much wider sources of data
such as i would say youtube again or
or similar type of scope and be able to
uh use that directly
on the other hand simulation does give
us a tremendous amount of power and
being able
to uh generate things very easily and
learn in variances
in a straightforward way um yeah i mean
i think this
is a lot of exciting work to be done in
this area
yeah with that i'm afraid we have to
um like close uh a little early today
and we will look at your questions and
maybe
come back to them thank you very much
for coming today everyone